um what i was talking about yeah i'm
gonna talk about two games today
um from the speeches championship
between uh
uh players who played there and uh even
though they were bliss games they were
like still
very high level mapping and there were
some really interesting
ideas especially in the openings that i
would like to discuss
and so yeah let's just get started
so the first game i would like to talk
about
is between wesley saw and the node back
up to
satorov um
so the game happened if the game
happened e4 e5 and the three knight c6
bishop c4
knight f6 knight g5 uh two knights um
the d5 it takes d5 and right now
there is a possibility to play
there are several possibilities for uh
for
for black one possibility here is to
play
a move knight takes d5
which is fried liver which is considered
as very suspicious but
we was with one of the viewers i used to
play here
uh is not entirely terrible as it's
supposed to be
but but yeah of course whiteboard should
be much better here afternoon takes d5
another possibility is uh b5 knight d4
and b594 all of those
possibilities are considered as slightly
dubious the main theory
uh is around move knight a5 here
so this is what another noddy black
played bishop b5
c6 d takes e6 b takes c6 right now
wesley played bishop d3
which is i think the best move
alternatives
are bishop e2 and queen f3 and those
moves i
think that black is doing well there
i think the bishop d3 is in general the
best strike here for white
and uh this is what generally what
should do if they want to
fight for an advantage and this is what
wesley played knight d5
this is all pretty much fury knight f3
bishop d6
short castle short castle rook e1 so
uh here is the position basically the
most important position of this
variation
right now black has three possibilities
i mean probably even more but let's say
three main possibilities that at least i
consider
one possibility is to play move uh queen
c7
simply um
depending upon the queen another
possibility is to defend the pawn only
five
uh with rook e8 and finally the third
possibility is to sacrifice
pawn on e5 with playing by playing move
f5
i'll discuss both all of them at first
let me start with move
queen c7 because i think this move is
not good for
for black and while show in a moment why
white we can play f4
knight f4 and bishop f1 and after bishop
f1
white is uh with white is in this okay
let's
go let me get back here with white is
playing uh
wesley saw with black no naughty back
abdu satorov and this is the game from
few days ago i think from uh speedchest
championship playgrounds.com
um from their match so
even though as i said even this was a
blizz game
that theoretical value that this game
has it's pretty substantial
and also um
west to play this i mean both players
played very well knowledge break also
played very well up to a point
wesley played entire game great so
uh we will let's see what happened so in
this position as i said
there's f5 there's rook gear and queen 7
after queen c7 which is
my opinion the most inaccurate c4 knight
f4 and bishop f1
i think that uh queen 7 doesn't do much
it's kind of like wasted tempe
and considering that white already uh
sorry the black already sacrificed the
pawn this queen c7 line
uh is queen seven move it's kind of
passive you just
try to defend and you're not creating
any threats and queensland is also
rather misplaced
if white wants to black wants to defend
this pawn if i roger we play because
sometimes maybe e4 will be supported or
something
here queen 7 doesn't do much in my
opinion so uh here
after bishop of c4 94 bishop by one i
think why this simply slightly better
for instance in the game of wesley so
but against paul pomkartov
uh played also in this year 2020 it was
blitz game
true but still uh still some game uh
pow power pokertov played f5 and uh
this is i think a big mistake because
after c5 suddenly
why i think was simply winning for
instance bishop takes c5
and right now rookie five is winning
westbrook's e5
rook d8 knight c3 this is just black
doesn't have any
compensation here and the pawn on sorry
knight on a5 is out of the
out of the not participating in the game
simply pawn down and no compensation for
for the first one night
night bishop d4 knight f3 trying to win
this pair of bishops
uh bishop f6 and finally d4 half extra
pawn
uh white is simply simply winning
c5 happened in this game queen a4 bishop
7 and finally bishop f4 wins a piece
and here uh wesley won
so this is one of the of course examples
why black played mistake
uh big mistake f5 uh trying to play e4
but already
f5 runs into c5 and this is this is uh
really
suddenly bad for black therefore black
should play move bishop g4 try to
lose bishop and uh pin this knight with
the queen
however still i think they have to move
like h3 let's say takes takes
knight d6 trying to control over uh
trying to control the dark squares
still is an extra point for white and
for instance after d3 may not be seven
let's say
bishop d2 i analyze let's say ideas
bishop d c3 and knight d2
also idea could be to play before right
now so while black should play probably
a5
bishop c3 knight c5 92 i think in this
position what is simply slightly better
uh with great perspectives to win the
game in the future
because extra pawn and the pair of
bishops
of course pair of bishops is not so
strong because bishop on the phone is
very passive
but still it doesn't take away that
white is better here and
only white can play for a win here
or like you know can but can also try to
play for a win but like it doesn't
change the fact that white is better
it has better chances so queen c7
uh is not the greater greatest approach
for from blacks
for black uh alternative is
move rook e8 and this is already much
better than queen e7 because this move
as i said earlier
supports e4 in many versions let's say
knight f4 and then if bishop
uh it comes to f1 then e4
can happen for instance the players
wesley saw against
no dearberry abdusathorov uh
from 2020 speeches championship rook e8
uh knight c and right now knight c3
knight as nf5 uh trying to play finally
e4
now if i had a four would knight 94 will
be inaccurate because neither
bishop f1 and the e4 is controlled
and neither flat knight for the knight
from e4 will be easily kicked out
so f5 makes a lot of sense
bishop f1 and e4 so here is the
another main position seemingly boy's
position is
kind of dangerous and indeed
from practical perspective it may not be
easy to play this play it with
with white black definitely has decent
compensation for
for the missing
[Music]
pawn however
still i think that white should hope for
some advantage here
for but it's not clear at all uh for but
for example
in the i think i love iranian played
against uh i think i mean boston even
though they're not confusing right now
uh knight d4 but knight d4 is already uh
inaccurate in an inner and inaccuracy
because right now black and play move
knight f6 and suddenly
knight on d4 is sort of loose there are
potential ideas of greek gift bishop
takes his major for queen h4
and i think that in general there are
certain problems here for for black
suddenly for for white i mean
let's say if h3 bishop c7 could be very
annoying
queen dc knight on d4 is hanging queen
d6 is coming
and if g3 let's say f4 also
opens the king side and black can
definitely hope for a good conversation
with
some attack of course it's not over it's
not like
you know it's so amazing
uh i mean the suddenly black is winning
but definitely
white is under pressure and i think if i
have to choose side here will be
definitely black
because bishop g4 f3 you know all those
ideas
maybe maybe also f3 all those ideas are
coming
white king is definitely very unsafe and
this is not what
white should generally try to play here
instead white should play knight takes
d5 not to allow this knight f6 to
retreat
after c65 now knight d4 that's why it's
a very important star with knight xd5
but knight hd5 on the other hand allows
black to build very strong center right
so this center definitely offers some
compensation for the missing pawn
queen f6 c3 and right now uh
black has some choice and
there is move knight c4 there's more
bishop b7 i announced those two moves
there are also others however
in general i think that white should be
somewhat better here but
it's very you know tiny advantage
and the in any in the game can anything
can happen because of the
complexity of the position and potential
compensation that black can get with
such strong center and potential attack
on the king side
for example united c4 d3 knight e5
looks very natural for black ideas of
knight g4
maybe f4 or something like this maybe
even knight f3 in the future
is they're they seem pretty dangerous
if knight b5 just bishop b8 i was
thinking
uh detects e4 and d takes e4 and here is
the question what to do here next with
white
and in my opinion
black needs to fix the knight on a5 what
do you mean fix the knight on a5
um knight
what what do you mean steve what i'm
trying to say is that knight
from a5 got back to to the center to the
to the e5 square and now right now
participate in the game
so this should be a really
good uh compensation here for for black
and maybe while it's still somewhat
better but like
it looks at least very dangerous from
practical point of view for example
queen h5 has to be played in my opinion
try to
sort of you know make some
maybe another queen active maybe get
bishop g5 or something but this is not
not clear at all after bishop seven what
is queen doing on h5
bishop g5 okay just queen somewhere
retreat let's take it to b6
and um not sure what next
like definitely black has some
conversation here like
you cannot like fill this day there's
extra pawn there is some dynamics in the
involved and uh it's very complicated
it's very
tough to say whether you know what is
better here like for
for real but the most important line is
queen d5
queen d5 seemingly wins the rook right
but after bishop e6 queen takes a8
uh suddenly it's possible to play
another three
while white won the rook but black is
actually
cruising like there's a snider f3 if g
takes f3
bishop takes h2 and simply takes the
rule takes the
queen with such weak king i don't even
though
black has two minor pieces on the rook
we have
exposed king on h2 uh black is not
taking any risk and only black can be
better
in my opinion so um
also queen h4 could be possible
technically but i really like knight f3
here
like this seems like very very strong
approach here by black and black
you know can be just simply better here
or at least not worse
so rookie 8 is possible as well it's you
know position is probably
like as i say in this line of queen h5
bishop seven
probably objectively white has some
advantage but it's not
really clear over the board because
there are lots of dynamics involved as i
said
and i think that
i mean i think that anything can happen
pretty much maybe even if white has
advantage it may be difficult to prove
it
uh so it's also a viable choice to play
rook e8
on 11th move finally let's discuss what
another back plate
he played f5 so this move sacrifices a
pawn right
and um after knight takes e5 queen f6
knight f3 and right now we go forward we
already sacrificed
not one not so we have to sort of
justify it and we can only justify by
developing some attack
so black has to play simply playing with
g5 and the question is simply
crazy uh it is extremely complicated
and i'm sure he was well analyzed by
wesley before he decided to play this
uh play this line so
a6 is a6 an idea to keep the knight
oh okay in the previous position uh well
i don't know to be honest i would have
to see the exact position right now
that they are talking about and uh
but in general i don't think so it could
be an idea but i'm not sure if there is
a great idea in that position
anyway talking about this g5
right now uh i think is his position is
very sharp and i'm
as i said i'm sure that west had to
analyze it very deeply
in order before he would decide to go to
go for it
because it simply looks very dangerous
to
white like let's say black plays g4 like
what you're gonna do with the knight
you see it's simply trapped that is
simply trapped
so wesley goes for a counter attack with
uh
c4 after g3 for instance black can play
maybe f4 and just go for
uh you know because g4 not h4 but f4
idea maybe you should g4
or then f3 and f3 is g3 sorry g4 and f
and left
g3 can be really really powerful too
so this position is suddenly extremely
unclear and but again it's so much so
much easier to play with black
rather than with white whose pieces are
still on the back ring almost all of
them
so uh this g3 will be a mistake probably
but once you play c4 neither f4 logical
bishop f1
g4 love very logical but right now
white loses the knight on f3 but manages
to sort of stabilize the position and
this is the this is the
goal white's golf here white played uh
what's he played d4 here
after gtx the three queen takes a free
so white gives back the piece
sorry white gives the piece for free
pawns
in total of three pounds and and tries
to stabilize the
position and actually destabilize
black's position first of all neither on
f4 is right now under attack
and i don't know if is on the edge of
the board is not doing much of course if
it's not let's say was suddenly here and
i just think block be totally winning
because just very strong attack
everything would be perfectly defended
but i know a5 is a problem here also
knight on f4 is under attack so
suddenly black's position even though
however you know great it seemed like
say here
super dynamic super you know aggressive
and organized
kind of like holding together suddenly
after this move like c4
after white sacrifices the knight it's
kind of
shaky so black needs to be extremely
careful right now
and i uh i think that black is doing in
general
in general well here but it is very
complicated
so let's see what what happened and what
could have happened let's let's see some
crazy chess because opposite
this position is absolutely crazy so uh
96 this is what happened in the game and
this is i think the best move
because
after knight g6 uh
would they just know jesus would be
simply too passive bishop d2 chasing
this knight
bishop and similarly bishop c3 suddenly
black is
called missing uh coordination and kind
of like uh
the pieces are misplaced on on the other
hand white just plays 92
next d5 maybe b4 maybe c5
all those moves are just coming very
naturally and
black in general has to be very very
careful
objectively i think white is simply
better
so g6 would be a mistake instead of the
g6 or 96 this move also queen
h4 and after queen h4 i think i should
play queen g3
queen take g3 h3 g3 entering the endgame
but still black's position are misplaced
let's say after knight d6 y can play c5
bishop e7 and bishop d2 again chasing
this knight away
bishop c4 again putting pressure on this
diagonal
on on the if and on the e file knight
bd8 and knight c3
and here of course white has three pawns
for
uh for the piece and great coordination
of the
of those pieces and idea is probably to
play at some point before and d5
to make uh to create two connected pawns
and proved that their way they're the
worth more than a piece
i think in general the white's simply
better here so this would be also very
passive
um similarly similarly after bishop
before let's say here this this
now the three positions kind of similar
probably this would be better for black
to play this but still another knight on
a5 and
like their lack of dark square bishops
also allows to explore
sorry invade on the on the dark squares
let's save some ideas of rookie 5 maybe
knight e5 maybe all kind of ideas here
for white as well so i think what's also
better here
so finally let's discuss what happened
in the game 96 which is
by far having the best move c5
and again right now there is a choice
for
for black queen d4 uh ibrahim uh
suggests but after queen d4 i think
there is some problem with rook d1
and suddenly all your pieces are hanging
and
uh i think that white is simply winning
yeah queen takes the four d1 very good
question guys uh
quintex d4 rook d1 and suddenly pawn is
bishop is hanging on
d6 uh because of the spin so we have to
go either quincy five or queen e5
let's say we go queen c5 we can maybe
play two so i can at least take this
this and this
and right now we have two x two pawns
for the exchange
black skin is miserable right now knight
on e5 is also very bad
all darts were overexposed so queen
takes d4 isn't
doesn't lead to anything good to black
does that make sense
just waiting in for chat
okay i assume it's clear i would like to
move on
so yeah the screen takes d4 just rope d1
and i think black is
uh lost after this move because of the
line
that i just said so after queen takes
the three knight e6 i think is the best
move
uh knight e6 and now c5
and right now black has probably more
but i think two decent options
uh [ __ ] knight xd4 is what happened in
the game which was a novelty actually
maybe at least two to my database
another possibility is to play bishop c7
and both
moves uh are possible however i think
that knight xd4 is objectively a
stronger move probably was preparation
by
uh not your back still because after
bishop c7 there was a game iranian uh
versus vidid in 2019 and after b4
queen takes d4 queen c3 it's very
similar to what we do
we just discussed after queen takes
three knight xt3 knight b7
bishop c4 uh
rook f6 for instance sorry another
graphics rookie 8
uh i meant and bishop assembly bishop b2
white has clear compensation here for
the missing piece
white black pieces are misplaced and b7
is terrible
can go to d8 true but you know
still all those pieces are very cramped
there is a pin on the
from this bishop on c4 also also from
rook only one
also blocking is exposed in general i
think that
white has this encompass decent
compensation here
cleveland restaurant uh after queen e5
i'll also take on d6
absolutely i would say also on d6 after
kuru queen eighty six
plays the four is just the same thing
so uh coming back to this position uh i
think one has decent conversation here
just to show
what uh happened in this game a5 b5
knight takes c5 bishop a3 knight e4
takes b6 and rook takes e4
of course could have been you know maybe
improve it here and there here or there
but in general
white always has compensation
and because of this pressure on this
diagonal and e file
and you cannot really feel this
advantage of a piece
right now it's more like about
initiative development
and uh dynamics rather than just you
know missing a piece
for instance king of seven rookie one
rook a seven and here
eleven iranian played very strong move
can you guys find it actually
not on this don't only move there are
also alternatives but like
can you find the move here for white
rook f4 it's possible it's possible it's
uh one of the
let's say good moves but
it's not what 11 played because after 4
i can just play maybe king
g let's say king g6 maybe
or something of course we have lots of
checks we have clear compensation i'm
not saying it's
you don't if you do but
the thing is if you play move like king
h1 and
prepare f4 f5 you just simply are
crushing on this uh
diagonal and of the e file and there is
nothing while
simply white can do so black can do
let's say a4 trying to stop with rogue
a5
f4 rg5 and suddenly just g4 and block is
simply busted f5 comes and
there is no uh
no way that black can uh
get out of the spin it's pretty much
lost already
so the lines the moves are suggesting
rook f4
like for in this position rook f4 is
good rook h4 is decent as well
however all those moves are uh
not f4 is not possible that's why king
we taking each one first
player four all the moves they are
suggesting are possible but they are by
far not the best
uh king age one by the f4 f5
is just extremely strong and i think
this is what i should generally do in
this position
this is what elevon did and he won
beautiful his game beautifully
so that's why in this position
probably it was not not earbuds uh
preparation to play knight takes d4 here
but not the knight xd4 queen c3
and here i think he made a mistake or he
confused his preparation
or i don't know but in general in this
position
black should play move bishop e5 i think
um
ignore design on a5 it's we don't need
this knight on a5 what's most important
right now
is the developing the initiative and
the dynamics
because bishop c7 is a passive move that
just defends the knight on a5 but
doesn't do anything dynamically instead
if you play b should be five
first of all you're creating afraid of
knight e2 and
if queen goes to a5 it goes to the edge
of the board collides this knight on a5
which anyway had no use
and meantime also bishop if i centralize
this bishop and
potentially create some attack on the
king's side so let's see what happens
first of all after queen takes a5
which is of course pretty much has to be
places there is rook e5 but this doesn't
doesn't lead anywhere because of uh
queen takes e5 let's say bishop e3
and we can play just rook d8 after queen
a5 right now
black can play knight f3 and rook d1 and
because of the spin on the back rank
from both sides black is simply
simply i will not say winning
but at least has great chances of of
being
winning here but yeah it definitely
looks very dangerous
to to white
so queen a5 is let's say better try but
right now simply f4
and the knight c2 also seemingly is very
natural but after knight c2
on the other hand by can play bishop g5
queen g5
and rook takes e5 and after knight xa1
simply queen c3 and even though white
has
what is down the rook knife for me why
is not coming to the game
and we can play bishop c4 next uh and
simply develop some initiative against
black's king
while black should sort of defend queen
g7 for instance f4
rook d8 bishop c4 and let's say kj892
however knight from ao has never come
into the game
and the white pieces are suddenly very
well placed they are greatly coordinated
and i think white is simply doing great
but
only only white can be better here even
though while black has extra rook
but for night from a1 is not coming to
the game
and the game is pretty much
i mean don't decide that i wouldn't say
desire but definitely is very dangerous
to play this with with black
also it's way easier to play with white
and you know just maybe knight f3 maybe
h3 king h2
slowly uh bring the pieces maybe the
knight g5
uh depending of course what white black
is doing but in general y has a
great compensation here for them for the
material
so knight c2 is possible it's kind of
risky so better
approaches to play f4 and immediately
try to create counter play on the
on the queen side in such positions you
just have to go for you know very
sharp play and uh do not think about you
know
missing two pawns just double the
initiative so
queen a4 analysis also has other moves
but let's say 92 after 92 simply bishop
f5 developing the piece suddenly black
has perfect development all active
pieces
and not not worse chances at all
uh in mapping position as i said it's
very complicated but
black is doing well if queen a4
right now bishop e6 after knight c3
black can simply baking h8 this call
move
seemingly we don't we wouldn't have we
shouldn't have time normally for such
move but the idea is very
strong because we just want because of
the g file being opened
we can if we place a rook on ga we can
simply create a very powerful attack on
the
on the king side so king h1
rook 88 for instance knight bishop d2
you somehow have to develop the pieces
on the king side sorry queen side
and finally knight f3 and black has very
powerful comb
initiative here and black should bail
out somehow the draw after
she takes takes queen take c6 and uh
let's say just rook g8
and i think that pawn
i mean sorry with the activity black has
here black is not taking any risk bishop
c4
i was considering as a good move i have
idea of having rook g1 because if
you know queen g5 could be a big threat
right now so we have to somehow solve it
because if does it because right after
queen jeff i'll be rubbing g1
and right now black can play simply rook
f2 and after queen a6 go for this end
game but after ug2
it's simply a perpetual check because
rugged h2 g2 we just
perpetual check so this is for instance
not this i mean id2 this this
would be just perpetual check rook g2
and with
withdraw right uh only thing i would
like no bishop h3 would actually lose
because after this this bishop d4 black
is able to defend the
the rook on f2 and also put some
pressure on
against black king against white king
because rujitu would just
be a mate right let's say just to show
quickly this
would be simply a checkmate right
so um
so this would be the correct play here
but by black and
what i'm trying to say is in general
black should go for initiative here
do not think about this knight on a5 2
too much like bishop c7 does
instead go bishop b5 go very active
queen e5 and the 4 look for quantum
player on the king side because this is
where black
generally should look for you know any
counter play here
and this is the way to do it bishop 7 is
also okay
quite okay it's a little bit dangerous
and definitely makes black star
blast black's task much harder than uh
then it should be after bishop b5
because after bishop c7
b4 uh black can uh
okay first let me show what happened in
the game because black played
knight b7 after knight b7 you see you
again
try to defend this knight is pretty much
useless now the b7 is
you know not doing much and after mp7
already
white is in uh in charge because after
bishop c4 k7
bishop b2 the the spin is pretty much
irresistible
suddenly rook d8 has to be played by
somebody knight d2 and i'd be free
the spin on this long diagonal is
just winning for white a5
knight b3 it takes before i suddenly
just queen takes d4 wins material
because there is this
white has simply extra exchange and the
game is just decided
i take it before here nadir break
resigned so this is how the game ended
however i would uh make i would
basically
miss one very important resource that
nobody breaks still had in this game
and which was after b4 not knight b7
this was a huge mistake in mp7
after bishop b2 bishop civil bishop 2
was winning as in the game
but i served an ip7
black has extra one extremely powerful
move and this is
found of course with with computers and
over the board is extremely difficult to
come up with such move
but nonetheless it works so the move is
simply move from b8
again ignore this knight on a5 what
matters is again the initiative
and the dynamics the playing possibility
b7
just loses and this is what happened in
the game this is just losing
you have to play dynamically and look
for counter play rook bf therefore
b8 and here i analyze two moves either
f4
or b takes a5 if the bj5 again bishop
has to e5
so here he will come again bishop only
five could be could have been placed
there immediately
right now uh it just comes back there
and uh it works still but like why would
you waste tempe for this
right so rook b8
uh this bishop e5 move needs to be
stopped so that's why white play here's
f4
and right now white has black has
against some choice there is possibility
to play
move queen g7 which i think is the
simplest the idea is
to first of all there is no post there
i mean um to put some pressure on g file
basically there's idea of knight f3 and
so on
and so stuff like that right so uh
here k1 i was thinking or b takes a5
if king h1 simply 96 makes sense and the
position
yes block this knight on a5 but white
loses a sort of
control over the position let's say this
bishop takes f4
takes takes bishop c3 otherwise we
cannot take this knight on a5 even
and again just reg8 go for dynamics and
just bishop e6
and with such powerful rook on b8 well
developed
and active bishops even though while
white has extra pawn
it simply doesn't matter if the position
is just around equal is very complicated
white has but in general black has no
reason to be worried here
this is one of the example lines if b
takes a5 uh
bishop takes a five quid takes the five
knight f3 position
becomes very tactical very complicated
more than
more even more than it was but in
general black
is doing well here let's say king h1
knight takes e1 bishop d2 trying to go
to
c3 but you know all those moves are
pretty much impossible to play over the
board
like uh it's so difficult right
like makes sense to maybe to maybe take
only one but e1 but then queen takes
away one was like
let's say this would run into this like
and
you know suddenly only one is hanging i
think black is simply winning
so bishop d2 and the idea is bishop c4
and bishop c3
it's it's crazy of course but like
it is what it is we should see three
queen d7 now bishop takes e1
and just queen d1 and i think black has
here great compensation
or like even not even conversation but
like great initiative
uh because yps are simply horrible
probably with best player like 22 for
instance black and eventually
after we have d8 y can eventually
somehow
make a draw but it is extremely
difficult
so this rook b8 and this line with queen
g7
like queen bc rubi8 and the queen g7
queenston is very difficult of course to
find but uh
black is still doing well and still
chances actually to be maybe even better
don't say why it's worse because
required play was okay
but i think that from practical point of
view
uh it is easier to play this with black
and
white is taking a little bit more recent
block
so this move rook ba was critical and
but finding it over the board especially
in this game because of online blitz
if you don't know it it's extremely
difficult
so uh the game ended with knight b7 and
bishop c4 as
i showed like a few minutes ago knight
d2
just to show it quickly again
this is how the game ended and
this was the result of move knight b7
which was
very passive move and such dynamic
position such crazy position
playing passive moves usually do not end
well
so this is one game that i want to talk
about today second game
i want to talk about today is was also
very interesting
and uh this was it was the game between
uh
between our eleven iranian and yani
pognashi
of course bob involved matches they
played many games i
specifically chose ones that i
let's say for my person on my in my
opinion were the most interesting ones
and the most let's say
uh educational ones and i think
uh i mean all of them were very
interesting of course because
no matter what games such players play
they for sure you can learn from them
but these are i think exceptionally good
so e4 c5 this this game right now is
aronian with white
pieces against yani publishing with
black pieces
e4 c5 knight f3 d6 d4 stays d4 knight
xd4
knight f6 knight c3 a6
night or new yanni pomache is one of the
biggest specialists in
najdorf
a free even though level aryan plays
or used to play in his entire life
mostly before recently he started
switching to
uh e4 and so e4 from him nowadays is not
a surprise
um f3 e5 this
english attack might be free bishop e6
bishop e3
this is all well known black has right
now
a huge choice the most popular move
right now is bishop e7
other very popular movies move h5
both very popular lots of theory lots of
studying
and so on uh also knight b7 is possible
uh all those moves are
are possible pretty much here however
the only permissions have played with
knight c6
and i always kind of like has suspicion
that this move could be sort of let's
say
i know not really sound because usually
you want to bring this knight to d7
play rook c8 kind of like use the c file
for uh
some activity now the item 6 i thought
doesn't really belong on c6
but modern theory proves that actually
is interesting
here white has big choice
queen d2 is by far let's say the most
logical move and the idea of move knight
c6 here is to play move d5
prepare d5 after it takes the fight
knight takes d5
takes takes everything bishop to sd5
long castle simply long castle
and this position surprisingly
uh such simple approach like you know
it's neither neither usually you know
you expect some big complications and so
on
after the opening and such let's say
simplistic play
um should give white some chances let's
say
because white has some initiatives still
let's say we should be saying is
possible and so on
um some maybe knight c5 jumps but it is
not easy to prove here any advantage
and i just want i just wanted to bri
bring up
one game between hikar nakamura and
niels grandelus from 2019
where hikaru didn't get any advantage uh
sort of showing that
black's approach here is pretty sound
let's say bishop the
bishop wait let me just find it bishop
d3 happen in this game
king c7 a3 trying to cover b4 square and
just simply bishop b7
rookie 1 h6 maybe ideas bishop g5 at
some point
and we shall f2 okay and right now there
is very simplistic approach by nils
bishop takes b3 c xb3 and just rook d7
root d8
very solid position no any problems a
pair of bishops
is only white scope but with
such you know solid position and
potential knight landing on d4 unlikely
while
it also potentially trading all the
rules on the d file unlikely what will
have any
serious uh
let's say uh chances to win this in the
game h4
after rook d8 bishop c4 all rooks were
swapped
and after f5 this endgame is pretty much
rubbish
for before just knight d4 and
let's just i'll just show a few more
moves bishop d5 bishop f6
staying in place pretty much
no no way to make progress heroes wide
because the spare of bishops
with this pair of bishops because light
only fire is very powerful there are no
any weaknesses
and eventually they came ended with a
draw because
uh hikaru finally decided to go for the
opposite opposite
color bishop even though he's trying to
down two pawns but of course there is
blockade and the game is simply drawn
uh actually he takes on b7 as well so uh
so actually just one point
uh so but in general yeah like there is
nothing that really white can hope for
uh here in this uh endgame
maybe some small pressure but like not
more than that
alternative after uh knight c6 would be
to play knight d5
will be interesting alternative and yes
as
pretty logical while black ones play d5
don't allow it right
so bishop takes d5 it takes d5 now
knight e7
and this is uh this is i think similar
to the lines
uh i'll just bring it up quickly of in
this position h5
uh let's say queen d2 or something
knight seven knight d5
visualized five edd g6 also this line is
which is also very interesting
and this line uh what uh happened what
could have happened in this game after
let's say knight c6
knight d5 bishop d58d97 is very similar
but there is one actually two big
differences one
for one black point is not on h5 but
still on h7
which i think is better when it's on h7
because it's not uh
really weakening the king side too much
another thing
is that knight is on not on d7 but that
is on uh
e7 and knight on e7
first of all attacks on d5 d5 right now
is one thing but also it can be quickly
developed to f5
so there is but only european knight
has all the advantages so it's debatable
which one
is strong which one is better in general
this structure
always is very playable for both sides
so
um so this is just an
alternative approach third approach
finally by uh
which was chosen by eleven is to play
queen e2 and ideas to sort of to prepare
against d5
because if d5 happens always some car
sort of let's say pin on the default
will be
uh and this could be an issue because
white will not have queen on d2 anymore
but
look on d1 which directly will be
playing on the difference so what i'm
trying to say is let's
for instance after this this at least
long cast has to be considered right now
and this pin on the d file could be very
annoying right
so this is wise idea on so in this
position
uh i wanted to show what yani pognashi
played because he played a novelty
he played move knight e7 actually in
this
this game we are mostly interested from
black's perspective so we flipped it
free play right now
so once again a queen e2 and right now
janine
actually played knight e7 and this is a
very interesting novelty
because seemingly like
you know it's playing against the rules
uh normally you have to play you know
play bishop e7 short castle little
pieces right and
here like you play knight six and play
for similarly for no reason play
knight d7 and
or if you want to develop this knight
bring it to d7 and then
play some normal chess right but this is
a new idea
actually it's not really new like this
idea exists in different variations in
naidorf
but the idea here of the e7 is to play
very quickly move d5
num basically after queen after queen d2
d5 was possible
after queen e2 is not possible but we
are preparing it by playing knight d7
because another piece will be supporting
d5 square and
we can bring it uh we can we can just
make it work
with d5 next on the next move so right
now uh
white has big choice i analyzed several
possibilities here for white
a long cast will happen in the game
which is the most natural if g4
simply h6 doesn't change much because h4
doesn't really work
uh i mean doesn't bring much because g5
then
phrases after h4 with g5 is still not
afraid because
let's say even if i first i'll play
probably d5 but even if i don't want to
play d5 and say rook c8
g5 this is not even a fret because
bishop plays g5
has to be played and this is not optimal
instead because hg would be of course
the rotation
rook takes h1 right so g5 is not put
another problem of course black
should play here d5 and just follow the
plan but just
just want to illustrate that h4 and g4
value of h4 isn't really a problem here
other possibilities to play with bishop
g5 after bishop g5
i found that simply queen c7 running
away from this pin and
again preparing d5 at some point is more
than sufficient to equalize
for instance after long castle and here
again
one totally surprising movie this
completely new approach that i've never
seen
before in my life is to play something
like a long castle
like i never seen something like this in
my life to play like
the chess like this in this opening uh
totally
new totally new like i never seen
something like this but actually it
works for black the idea is again to
play very quickly d5
normally of course you want to go the
king to the short side but here long
castle
followed by d5 pretty much solves all
the problems in the opening
analysis queen f2 but simply d5 takes
knight takes d5
okay rook takes d5 rook d3
trying to play b smile and play rook c3
but simply we can take it take a knight
d5
after queen a7 just queen b8 no any
problems
just equal position and no any problem
suddenly
very interesting and very
new like approach here by bob light that
i never seen
in my life before because usually you go
short for shortcuts to try to hold the
attack on the king side sorry queen side
here however the plan is totally
different you some pre-pro
you prepare simply d5 i never seen in my
life before this is
uh like i mean i saw ideas to prepare d5
and but to prepare it with long castle
in such position never this is totally
novel for me
but anyway i was happy to discover and
i'm happy to share with you guys
so 97
uh suddenly is very interesting choice
by by black and novelty by ryan pomercy
i don't know if level knew it he played
long castle which is the most natural
move but of course right now how
d5 follows it takes d5 knight takes d5
that takes d5 and takes d5
so uh because the king is on c1
c4 doesn't we really win a piece because
we can play something queen c7
just to put on the board c4 let's say
quick c7 and we are
we black is doing okay
and so therefore 11 play move king b1
and after kim b1
again queen c7 again
there are no any absolutely any issues
with black's position usually
uh i mean black
the idea was black's idea of beginning
d5
usually solves problems and even black
can get to d5 so
easily it should be played pretty much
so
this is the id7 idea suddenly could be
really powerful
and uh black could be simply better not
not better but like uh
so could it solve all the opening
problems on the spot
so after queen c7 i think black is doing
already great
after bishop c1
uh bishop e7 you know of course knight x
e3
white shouldn't be alarming knight takes
e3 so it makes sense to retrieve
retreat with this bishop we should be 7
right now
and right now i think it was time for
white to begin
thinking about the quality because white
is not better anymore
and playing for a win right or like you
know trying to
prove advantage or something like this
is a little bit
too much like you should try to think
about how to not to get
much worse and make sure you are safe
rather than just to try to play for an
advantage
so queen e4 is what levon played and
this is playing for uh to approve to
prove an advantage but it's already a
mistake
instead probably queen c4 had to be
played try to enter an end game
and try to sort of hold it position
should be around equal maybe black
black expression is a little bit
preferable but in general opposition
should be around equal
uh queen e4 on the other hand happened
and i'll just rook c8
right now queen c4 is not possible
bishop c4 is not possible
also rook takes d5 very important is not
possible because bishop takes d5 queen
takes e5 queen takes c2
after king a1 king's queen c1 is a
checkmate
so taking on d5
this doesn't work therefore 11 plate
moves c3 but after c3
the queen runs into f5 and here suddenly
black is on
in total control like black has great
position and
great perspective of actually winning so
uh here level made a
horrible mistake play queen e4 probably
the reason
for mistakes here or and so on i'm
not probably i'm pretty sure because it
was blitz games
and it was uh he was probably surprised
and there was some sort of the mistakes
here uh so
um after a fight he played queen a4
which was a big mistake he had to play
queen one try to make it
solid to try to try to play solid after
king f7
sort of it's the king of sun is actually
sort of castling because
uh rook comes to d8 next
but the thing is the king of seven is
actually better place than on g8 because
it supports bishop on
any case for instance after let's say
short castle
sorry no another rogue fighter castle
white would all black will always have
to worry about moves like knight d4 or
something that is not sure if it works
but at least you have to worry about
with king on f7
bishop and bishop on e6 is well
supported and the rook fda rook hd8 is
coming next
so i think black is still better here
but
white at least is sort of solid here
after queen a4
suddenly after king f7 again queen on a4
is nearly trapped
it has no future here at all and again i
have the bishop d3 rook hd8
alternative cool already quintex e3
which
wins simply a pawn because bc knight
takes e3 and is a fork
but there is not even need for no even
need for this
because rook hd8 simply brings
final piece to the game look just have a
look guys at this
dominant coordination of black's pieces
everything's perfectly located and the
queen on a4 is bad like it's very likely
that it's gonna be at some point trapped
so if g4 for instance
suddenly knight b6 just wins the queen
queen a5 and rook d5
the queen is trapped the queen has
nowhere to go and black simply wins move
number 20 and this is game over
and if queen a5 of course we do not
trade queens we play queen c6
after queen c6 g4 happened
and here uh by some reason any pokemon
she missed
i guess his possibility to win here with
move b6
which is pretty simple tactics and
probably i mean
i'm pretty sure the reason for this was
because it was blitz
and uh in normal game he would never
miss this
after queen queen a697 queen a7 does
rook a8 just traps the queen
but as i say like in blitz sometimes
unexplicable
things happen so unexplainable things
happen
so uh b6 26 knight seven under okay
eight simply wins the queen
he played g6 takes takes rook age one
and again a b6 he was winning
by some reason he played with bishop f6
trying to play bishop
knows more solid again b6
and the same thing happens and black
wins not sure what he didn't see or what
what happened but probably it was
because it was just
nature this is the nature of basically
to play quickly bishop f6 just try to
protect the pawn
and see what the opponent does but like
okay b6 just wins right
so but so probably just the reason for
this was uh that
you know shorter time control bishop f6
bishop c2
and right now the game entered you know
huge uh
complications because right now beats
after b6 is still winning
but it's not not as clear as it was
before because
right now queen can escape bishop on the
is not
not on d3 and queen can escape back
after 97 let's say
but white can play sorry back and play
with that before and go for direct
attack
and here again black is winning knight
c2 king c2 and simply queen a4
black is winning but position is still
quite complicated
rook c3 king b1 and
rookie very nicely played by young
queen takes h7 and right now
probably both players were already in
big time trouble because
suddenly both of them both strong super
stronger masters but
started making huge mistakes right now
king g8
and the wider simply runs out of checks
and black mates on the king side
queen side let's say queen h5 or queen
g6
doesn't matter that bishop f7 game is
over
note anymore checks that's it and queen
a2 next
checkmate that that's pretty much that
seals the deal
pretty much uh bishop g7 happened in the
game however
and right now after queen h5 suddenly if
king goes to e7 there's bishop g5
available check
if king goes to back to g8 suddenly
there is contact with rook d8
very powerful move by 11 who which saves
the game
uh or x prolongs the game or like that
uh rook d8 b takes c3 rookie 8 back
and rookie 2 and right now uh
still why black is much better probably
winning after simply you know
playing e4 and opening this bishop from
g7 to join finally the attack
or playing f4 maybe preparing at some
point you know maybe rook f8 bishop f5
uh
try to maybe all we're just stabilizing
let's say the position a little bit
and positionally black is simply
dominant here so black uh
should should win this however level uh
sorry any opponent should play queen b5
pro i mean this move number 33 after
such complicated you know opening and
middle game
and i'm sure that both players had
very little time so it could be
there must be an explanation for their
mistakes here because after queen b5
right now levon could play rook g2 and
this would save the save the game right
now suddenly because
rook to h7 is always enough sufficient
compensation
after bishop takes b3 at xb3 queen takes
b3 suddenly rugby 2 back
queen 6 and rook g2 back again looking
for counter play always with connective
rook to h7
and some summing on against black's king
pretty much saves the game position is
simply equal right now
and if queen d3 of course just can be
two after takes a takes b3
e4 seemingly uh queen you know queen
c3 or something like this is unstoppable
but rook g7 suddenly simply is just a
perpetual check
king g7 just given g5 kf7 queen f5
simply you know makes saves the game for
for white
so but 11 played rook b2 which is a very
human move because you know rogue is
hanging on before he's hanging
bring it bring it up to the defense uh
however
it's it's simply lost right now because
after queen d3
king a1 again just e4 wins the game but
as i say both players one hundred
percent were in time trouble because
the yanni polished to play queen d1
which is a
mistake that spoils everything right now
rook d2
would have you know bring back to life
again
and after queen f1 uh just bring the
king
again and this is like let's say king i
think b1
i think it's okay like maybe or sorry
king b2 is okay
king b2 to be to be more precise and uh
still
still something going why is better so
black is better but it's still
you know not not totally winning or
totally lost for either of the sides
instead here uh levon played queen g5
but
this is just a blunder because our
bishop takes b3
the game is just decided just drops the
entire entire uh
the the whole knight because ruby is
impossible because quickly it's be free
and that's that's it so this is the game
divorce are the games actually uh very
interesting
both lots of things were happening in
both of them in
the first one we had a great preparation
by
wesley saw but position was extremely
complicated
here also great preparation by annie
pognashi
who came up with this idea of bringing
it up again
in this position 97 which basically
uh prepares d5 and seemingly i don't see
how
white would be able to stop this and
black black angus to d5
black solves all the opening problems in
general so do beat from me for today i
hope you guys
like the games and
they were interesting and i will see you
next time thanks